80% українців категорично проти
проведення будь-яких виборів під час
воєнного стану українці вважають що
треба перемагати влаш впорядковувати
державу налагоджувати процеси а тоді
можна думати про вибори бо вибори в
будь-якому випадку це з одного боку це є
розкол суспільства по політичних
вподобаннях з другого боку це є
можливість Московської Федерації
будь-яких наших інших ворогів
маніпулювати інформаційним простором і
знищувати нас з середини а з третього
боку у нас немає жодних можливостей
реально провести чесні демократичні і
відкриті вибори навіть стефанчук в своїм
обговоренням навіть зачіпаючи питання
військовослужбовців він відкидає
можливість військових голосувати тому що
військовослужбовці сьогодні щомиті
боронять цілісність нашої держави ще раз
наголошу що це напевно Вони намагаються
залишки свого рейтингу врятувати поки
всякі безмозлі створіння взагалі не
загробили їх до тотального нуля